PROFESSOR: Welcome back to
[? A20, ?] special relativity.
Very early in this lecture,
we discussed what mass is
and how we can understand
the mass of a proton
and the mass of an electron
as it interacts with the Higgs
background field.
But here, the question
is slightly different.
You want to understand
the difference or the lack
of difference between the
mass in a gravitational field
compared to the inertial
mass, a mass being
pushed through some force.
And it's probably Einstein's
biggest realization
that those two
things are the same.
And that finding is called
the equivalence principle,
the equivalence of the
gravitational and inertial
mass.
So if you are a
freely falling person,
you will not feel
your own weight
in your gravitational field.
You will just drop.
And the gravitational field
provides an acceleration.
And that acceleration, if you
are standing in an elevator
or just sitting on a chair
like I'm doing right now,
then sets up an accelerating
reference frame.
So there is an equivalence
between being accelerated
or being stationary in
a gravitational field.